[Music]
I'm Ken Duncan I'm the founder and chief
creative officer of Duncan animation
studio and I'm here to tell my story my
name is Stephanie Alexander I am a
storyboard revisionists and animator and
I'm here to tell my story
yeah I've been drawing since I was
really young I still have a comic book
that I did with a friend at the age of 8
we did a 50 page comic book we were
always drawing cartoons my sister told
me about this guy Walt Disney and I went
to the library and read about him and I
thought his life is so cool and he was
doing cartoons so from then on I wanted
to be an animator so I've always wanted
to draw I've been drawing since I was
really little and I got really serious
about drawing probably when I was around
10 years old I would buy pretty much
every how to draw book that I could find
in high school I started to find visual
development books for animated films and
that inspired me to go into animation as
a field actually one of my biggest
mentors was when I started to work in
the industry ended up in Europe and I
worked in London for an Oscar Grillo
Argentinean gentleman who had a studio
in London doing commercials and I learnt
a lot from him he was an amazing artist
and he owned his own studio so it's kind
of inspiring that he he could do both so
one of my earliest mentors in school was
David Brooks MA he was at the time and
elke had one of the co-chairs of my
major and he was xas knee he really
inspired me to develop my animation in
art style further my first job in
animation was during college our teacher
was being asked to be an animation
supervisor in a studio in Paris he was
looking for an assistant and a bunch of
us put in our portfolios and I was hired
to go to Paris and work on an animated
feature my first job coming out of
school was as a animation assistant on
Mary Poppins Returns and I got that job
actually through my mentor David Brooks
ma kin at Duncan studio reached out to
him first to come on as an animator and
when he couldn't he put forward several
students including myself to go in and
test for an animation assistant position
eventually I got the job so my career
really began in Europe I worked on
features I went to London to Madrid
working on commercials and ended up in
Ireland
working on a film called land before
time so for most of my career I've been
an immigrant for 35 years working in
Europe in the United States about a year
after coming to United States I ended up
at Disney in the 1990s I've been in this
industry now for two years officially my
first job out of college was Mary
Poppins returns as an animation
assistant and when that was done I was
eventually brought on at a studio called
oddbod Inc to work as a storyboard
revisionist on Muppet Babies where I am
currently located working with Ken and
the crew at Duncan Studio on Mary
Poppins was a really incredible
experience for me a lot of the staff a
lot of the people there were ecstasy and
were people that I had grown up watching
you know I would be talking with an
animator and he would just in passing be
like oh yeah I animated that frame of
the Iron Giant that you see right there
and I would just be like oh my god that
was one of the things that inspired me
to become an animator I feel I became
successful or made it as they say
probably when I became a supervisor at
Disney on a film called Hercules I did
the Meg character well thanks for
everything of work it's been a real
slice and then after that I did the Jane
character in Captain Elliott yeah
Treasure Planet and dr. again with the
greatest possible respect zip your
howling screamer so during that phase I
really felt they had made it as a
supervising animator I thought when I
had started on Poppins that that was
when I made it because it's like oh this
is my dream job this is what I've always
wanted to do and I quickly realized once
I was a few months in that you still
have to figure out what comes next you
have to figure out what comes after this
I think animation is an industry you
never quite feel like you make it
because there's always something new and
challenging around the corner for you
that's kind of what helps keep people in
a way humble for many decades animation
in general it was an unwritten rule that
sort of men were the animators and women
were the assistants or the cleanup
department I've talked to a couple of
women about this and they they truly
felt this
so first anybody to be an artist or an
animator you need some help some
assistance and some encouragement so
if there was a feeling that you weren't
getting encouraged I think it dissuaded
people from advancing I have
occasionally kind of been the butt of a
joke or two of like oh you're a pretty
good animator for a girl it's a small
offense it's not something that I really
take to heart but I do think that it's
kind of a symptom of a greater problem
we're challenging those old ideas about
where a woman or minorities place is in
this industry so I did work really hard
to get where I am I'm not really good at
what I do in spite of being woman I'm
really I'm just really good at what I
set out to do because I put that time
and effort into it my goals for the
future
for the studio really we're trying to
develop our own content and currently
working on a feature film idea that
really has a female lead and has an
ecological aspect to the story the
female doesn't need a male character to
help her we've also got a sci-fi series
etcetera so looking forward to creating
some really cool stuff my goals are
always changing as a storyboard
revisionists right now as somebody who
works in other people's boards I would
love to have a chance to do storyboards
myself and maybe even eventually get
into directing but there's definitely a
part of me that wants to go back into a
traditional animation field and into a
project that really brings attention
back to that art form which I really
admire about Duncan Studio and Ken's
work is that he does keep that alive and
I think that that's really admirable for
kids who really want to be an animator
it's really important to be curious and
to really research and to study people
study life study design and really reach
out to other people that have done the
art form to learn from them if you
pursue the art form that you love you're
going to do just fine
it's challenging but it's incredibly
rewarding you need to make sure that
you're putting the effort in putting the
time and you're really learning film
language and learning how to be a team
player learning how to
elaborate I would say this industry is
part luck part who you know and a big
part being prepared the relevant skills
a real portfolio when an opportunity
arrives because I've missed
opportunities because I wasn't ready and
I've gotten opportunities because I've
been ready in order for our animation
art form to advance we have to be more
inclusive to include people from
different cultures including more women
to get their point of view on stories
and to really show the world a new way
of looking at entertainment I think that
animation is wonderful it's it's a great
medium and it's unlimited and what you
can tell in animation and that's what I
really admire about it
[Music]